[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN CIRULI: My
name is Dan Ciruli,
and I'm a product
manager here at Google.
And you, I hope, are here to
learn about SLOs and error
budgets.
This is the most awkward
stage I've ever been on.
Conveniently, none
of you are going
to look at me the whole time,
so I guess it doesn't matter.
My name's Dan's Ciruli.
I'm a product manager at Google.
I've been here for
about six years
working all on services and API
infrastructure and products.
I now focus on Istio
and our service mesh
efforts, both open source and
in our commercial products.
You will hear some
other voices today.
We will bring up another
very skilled product manager
from Google, Ruxanda Danetiu.
She works exclusively really
on service and SLO monitoring.
She thinks a lot about the role
of the operator, the service
operator.
And we're going to bring
up one of our customers,
Pod Sandhu comes to
us from Schlumberger,
a very experienced
SRE there where
he not only spends his
time kind of as an SRE
but also evangelizing
best practices.
And a couple of us are on
Twitter, and one of us,
I guess, is refusing to join.
So I'm going to spend some
time today talking to you
about SLOs and error budgets.
Ruxanda is then
going to demonstrate
some of the software that
we've been working on
and which is available
in alpha today,
and then Pod and
Ruxanda are going
to have a discussion
about how they are using
the alpha software today and how
they think about SLOs and error
budgets at a fairly
sophisticated organization.
So we'll start by talking
about SLOs and error budgets.
And if you've seen me talk
about this before, if you've
seen any of our SREs,
you know anytime
we give a talk like
this, we always
start by talking about
SLIs, SLOs, and SLAs.
And it may be review for some
people, but for some people
they get confusing.
It's important to
understand what we mean
as we refer to each of them.
So we'll spend just a slide
talking about what each of them
are.
But SLIs are metrics,
SLOs are targets,
and SLAs are the promises
you make about those.
So we start with SLIs.
The important thing
to know is that this
is a quantitative measure.
There was a time when there
was up and there was down.
There was a time
when is the site up?
Isitdown.com was
a thing we used.
And really, that's
how we measured
whether something was working.
Was it up or was it down?
But we've gotten
past that, and now we
think about defined
quantities that we
can measure so that we can
all in an organization,
from the people who wrote
the service to the people who
were running it, agree
on what the targets are
we're going to set.
So it's an aspect
of the service.
The ones we generally think
of are what we at Google
call the golden signals.
For anyone who has
read the SRE handbook,
you'll know that there's four
golden signals for a service.
There is traffic,
how much traffic
is hitting that service.
There is error rate.
What percentage of those
requests that come in
are not resulting in errors?
There's latency, and latency
is not just a single number,
but rather it's a bunch
of numbers we measure.
It's how long to take a request.
We measure the time it
takes to serve requests,
but we do that at
different percentiles.
And the reason is that
the 50th percentile,
your average request
length, isn't always
indicative of what's
happening, and what
we tend to see is
that at the tail,
at the 90th
percentile, the 95th--
depending on your
traffic levels,
99th percentile-- you will
often see unacceptable results.
And so we measure
it out there too.
And we often divide use as
SLIs both the 50th percentile
and the 99th because
you might say, hey,
we want under 200 milliseconds
for the average user.
That might be OK.
But it might not be OK for the
99th to be at 20 milliseconds.
And so it's important to
monitor those and agree
that these are things
we're going to care about.
There's a fourth golden
signal that our SREs refer
to as saturation,
and saturation is
different for
different services.
Sometimes it might
be hardware related
like it might be how much
RAM is being consumed
or what CPU percentage you're
using, but it can be different.
It might be number of
current active user sessions.
It can be different
for different services,
and sometimes people
define custom metrics,
and they have their app
actually writing metrics out.
The important part is that
you agree in your teams what
you are going to measure.
Now Istio, for its part,
gathers most of these.
It gathers traffic.
It gathers error rates.
It gathers latencies
so that you can then
have discussions about where
you want these metrics to be,
and that's where we get into
service level objectives, SLOs.
A service level objective,
basically it's a target.
It's what you consider
to be acceptable.
It's sometimes a range
you want to stay above,
like you want your
successful rate
to be above you say
99.95% of your requests.
It might be a value
you stay below,
like you want 50%
of your requests
returned in a hundred
milliseconds or less.
And sometimes it ends up
being a range as well.
These things can be defined
very, very granularly
on each microservice
in your application,
and it's a good idea to do that.
We believe strongly in
measuring these things
for every single service
that we deploy, and we do.
We monitor every service
no matter how small.
We monitor these metrics.
We are also moving to something
we call user-centric SLOs.
And user-centric SLOs aren't
defined in terms of how long
does it take this particular
service to return a request
but rather how long
does it take from when
a user clicks, say, a Save
button to when it returns.
And that might
involve lots and lots
of requests on the back end.
It might involve a chain of
requests from the client,
and it almost certainly involves
measuring it from the client.
We're not going to get too much
in user-centric SLOs today.
They're actually
a fairly new thing
that we're evolving
on in Google.
It's difficult to instrument.
You might actually have to start
measuring in the client app
itself.
But it is an important
concept to know about.
And one thing about an SLO is
you may alert somebody when you
go out of compliance with them.
You won't necessarily.
An important concept
that our SREs talk about
is alert fatigue.
Just because you've set a
goal and you're not meeting
it momentarily doesn't mean
you need to wake somebody
up in the middle of the night.
We'll talk a little bit
more about alerting later.
And then finally there's SLAs.
SLAs are agreements you make
with somebody about your SLO.
When I say you, I mean you're
the producer of it's service.
Sometimes these are informal.
It might be just an
informal agreement
you have in your
company about, hey,
we need your service
that we're depending on
to succeed 99.9% of the time.
It might be that the worst thing
you get is the ire of that team
if you violate it.
However, these are
often legal agreements.
And those of you who are Google
Cloud customers have probably
seen or at least heard about--
we have pages where we document
exactly how we will intend to
run the service and what we
will do for you if we don't.
In that case, it means
generally rebates and money.
And these are generally set
on, of course, the SLOs.
So we start with the SLAs.
We set objectives,
and occasionally we
make agreements about
those objectives.
So I said before we used
to talk about uptime a lot,
and uptime was basically how
much time was there total
and how much that
time was up and what's
the ratio between
those two, right?
And that made sense when
we were talking about sites
and we were talking
about something
it was either going
to return or not.
Things are more complicated
now that we deal with services.
Both of these
graphics, by the way,
are taken from the SRE handbook.
Now we think more really
about aggregate availability
where this will take
into account the fact
that a service is global.
It's not a single thing.
It's running across the world
in different data centers.
And if it's down in one and
up in another, is that up
or is that down?
Well, aggregate availability
takes that into account.
It's the number of requests
that were attempted
in the denominator,
and the numerator
is the total number of requests.
Now interestingly, we
still define our SLAs
in uptime at Google for
many of our services.
And to do that, we combine
them, and we'll say things
like downtime is any five-minute
period where more than 10%
of our requests are failing.
And then we make a
request about downtime--
I mean we make a guarantee about
downtime and how little of it
we expect there to be.
So in reality, we are measuring
aggregate availability,
but we look at that
in discrete chunks
so that we can define uptime and
define downtime and really give
an SLA that people
can understand.
Now I want to talk a little
bit about error budgets.
So that's SLIs, SLOs, SLAs.
Now let's get into
error budgets.
The point behind budgets
is that every time you
push new software,
you're taking a risk.
When your system is up and it's
running and you're in stasis,
it's probably going to stay
running unless you write memory
leaks, which I know you don't.
But if you don't, then
you're probably OK.
The risky times for software is
when you're doing a deployment.
Every push is risky.
Error budgets exist to
help us manage that risk.
And basically you can think of
it as SLO that you can spend.
Time that you're within
your SLO does not
count against your
budget, and time
that you're not within your
SLO counts against your budget.
So you define an SLO over
a long period of time.
We typically do this for a
month or often over a quarter,
and we say as long as
you are within budget,
you can continue
to push software.
You can continue to take risks.
However, that budget
exists over that quarter
to help you manage
that risk and to force
you to manage that risk.
If every moment you're
out of compliance,
you're spending your budget,
and if you go out of budget,
you can't push new features.
You can still push, but
everything at that point
can only be pushed to help
improve your infrastructure,
to help address
the problems that
is making your system go down.
So your quality pushes
continue, but your feature
pushes do not continue.
If you have ever been excited
about a new feature you heard
about, maybe at a conference
like this from Google,
and you were expecting
it in a certain quarter
and it didn't ship
that quarter, it
may be because
engineering is hard,
but it may be that
they ran out of budget
and they literally
weren't allowed to push.
This is something that we
work very religiously--
I shouldn't say religiously, but
we work very diligently toward.
And this is something that
really aligns engineering teams
and operations teams.
The operations team is
really incented to keep
the system up and running
and to build infrastructure
to keep the system
up and running.
That's what our SRE do.
And they'll push
back on the dev team,
and if the dev team won't
do it, well then they're
going to push something
bad and they're going
to run out of error budget.
And so here you can
see a chart where
we've got our SLO is
a dotted line there.
It's a red dotted line.
The time that we're above, we're
not burning through our budget.
And I chose one
where we're burning
through a lot of budget.
And if you look up top there--
I thought we had
one more build--
you can see we've
got 125 minutes
remaining in our error budget.
This is April.
There's two months left.
The service is in dire trouble
right now because they've only
got two hours left.
They've burned through
95% of the budget.
So that's how you use a budget.
It's to manage risk.
And in order to
do it, you really
have to adopt it for
real, and you really
have to say no one will
push if we're out of budget
for the rest of the quarter.
When you start looking
at it that way,
it really lets you
manage your risk.
On the other hand if it's
towards the end of the quarter
and you've had a
great quarter, you
can afford to push
more frequently.
One of the original
SREs at Google
used to say what's the use
to having all these knives
if we don't take them out
for a spin once in a while?
When you've got lots
of budget, push it.
Push it.
Push those features.
But it lets you manage the risk.
It lets you reason together
as a development team,
as an operations team.
I talked a little
bit about alerting.
Alerts are not necessarily for
when you are out of budget.
Alerts are for when
something's on fire,
when something is down.
When your error rate is over 10%
and you're on the spanner team,
you're getting woken up.
That's what alerts are for.
Budgets are more like when your
infrastructure needs repair.
If you're running out
of budget for a quarter,
it tells you you need to
spend some of your cycles
right now in improving
your infrastructure
and improving your test
processes, improving
your release processes.
That's where you should
be spending your time.
And a final note
about canaries--
one of the reasons we
do canaries, of course,
is so that if there's a problem
in a service as we release it,
we don't affect all of
our users at once, right?
Of course, but these
play into budgets as well
because when I canary my
release and expose it only
to a small number
of users, yes, I
am guaranteeing that
if there's a problem,
it's only going to affect
a small number of users,
but I'm also not
blowing my budget.
If there's a problem and
it affects 100% of my users
for 10 minutes, that might
be my budget for the quarter.
If it affects 1% of my
customers for 10 minutes,
I might still have a budget.
So one of the things
we use canaries for
is to help manage your
budget and to help
make sure that you
are-- again, it's
really about risk management.
It's about making sure that
you catch these problems
before they affect you overall.
So that's what I have about SLOs
and error budgets in theory.
Now Ruxanda will
talk a little bit
about what we've
built in the software
to allow you to do this stuff.
RUXANDA DANETIU: We
really appreciate
understanding how these SLOs
work and the error budgets as
well.
So at this point, we want
to see how these actually
work in real life.
So what we are actually
trying to do here
is that Stackdriver has worked
really closely with the Istio
team, and we wanted
to provide a solution,
a service-management
solution, that
can empower users to get out
of the box telemetry that
requires zero setup.
Our main goal is to empower
all of our customers
to have one single dashboard
for both management
and observability.
You have the single place
where you can go and look
at all of your metrics, without
having to worry about agents,
without having to
change context,
without having to think
about this too long.
Everything is out
of the box for you.
So I'm going to welcome
Patrick to the stage.
Patrick is the lead engineer
working on service monitoring,
SLO monitoring,
and topology graph,
and his team has built
a lot of the features
we're going to demo today.
I had the immense
privilege of working
with him on the past
couple of months
of putting this together.
So while Patrick
sets this up, I want
to really understand what
we're going to show right now.
It is the alpha product
that we are launching
at Next for service management.
So you're coming
here, and you're
going to see a list of
all of your services,
your Istio services that have
deployed to the Istio mesh.
And really what we built
embedded from the beginning
is SLO monitoring.
This is one of the things
that we cared about deeply.
So at the top you can
easily see which services
have SLO-based alerts firing
or not, which of your services
have SLOs out of your budget.
And some services,
exactly as Dan
said, some of these
services, you're
not going to set
up SLOs for them.
You're not going to end up
alerting on them because not
everything is as
important, and we're
going to talk about
how to prioritize that.
In addition to this,
you can actually
review all of your services.
So you get a list of all of
your Istio services right here.
You can easily filter based
on the things you care about,
and you get this out
of the box telemetry.
What this view is
missing is that when
you have-- imagine 300,
500 of these services.
It's really hard
to figure out what
to prioritize, what to look
for, how to do root cause
analysis in this format.
So what Patrick's team has
built is a apology graph.
This is a way for us
to actually visualize
all of the relationships
between these services.
You can actually see at a glance
how all of this information
gets transferred.
If you hover on any
of these services--
on the left-hand side
you see the legend
that shows you which
one are workloads
and which one are
services so you
can differentiate between them.
And when you hover
on one of them,
you get actually
highlighted information
of what are the inbound
and outbound services.
Here you can also see the QPS
based on those relationships
as well.
So I spent a lot of time
talking to customers when
we built this
functionality, and we really
wanted to get to kind
of the root cause.
How do customers currently
think about their architecture?
And a lot of the
feedback that I received
is that there is a picture, a
really awesome picture that's
been sitting in a folder
for the past six months
of a whiteboard, a PDF
that hasn't been updated
in two to four years.
And every time they onboard
somebody new to the team,
they have to start
taking pen and paper out.
The benefit of this, if you
look at the bottom timeline,
it says 4:59 PM.
So what happens here is
that we are extracting
all of this information,
and we give you a view
of your architecture right now.
And this is key because
you might care about how
your architecture is today.
But let's say it's
Monday morning.
You come into the office.
You look at a
postmortem, and you
realize that you had an
incident on Friday at 4:00 PM.
And you're reading
the postmortem,
and you have some questions.
You're trying to
evaluate what happened.
So we built this feature--
we call it a time machine.
We thought it was a cool name--
where you can go back in time.
You can go and look
at your architecture
at 4:00 PM on
Friday, and you can
see how all of your services
looked around that point.
And that is great.
However, that just
gives you an idea
of how your world looked
when the incident happened,
but what you care about
is what has changed.
So maybe you want to look
at your architecture an hour
before and an hour after.
And you can do that maybe
like switching really, really,
really fast and maybe can
get dizzy in the process.
So what the team has
built is this notion
of doing a time
diff between these.
So you're looking
at the cartservice.
This is the service that
you see you have the alert.
And then you notice that
from the cartservice,
the checkout service right
there, the workload at the top,
is where the information
is coming through.
That's one of the source.
So let's expand
that for a second
and look at the cartservice.
You look at the workload.
You see you have a deployment,
and within that deployment
you notice that you
have these pods.
So OK, this is good information.
You want to see the world, how
it looked before and after.
So let's turn the time
diff mode on and be
able to select two
points in time, one hour
before your alert and one
hour after so we can actually
see the differences between
that workload and see
is there any change there?
Can we actually spot any
difference between those two?
So what we're noticing here
is that an hour before we
had two pods, and an hour after
the incidents we had five.
This is helping you
do root-cause analysis
at a glance--
powerful, visual--
without having
to go through a bunch
of logs, without having
to go through a lot of metrics.
You can see these differences
right at the spot right there.
And you can do this
in different modes.
This is kind of my favorite
one where you can actually
hover over and see as these
changes are being made.
And the idea here
is that what we're
trying to empower
our users is to be
able to do your troubleshooting
as fast as possible
and to do that in the moment if
it's a 3 o'clock in the morning
or to be able to put yourself
in the shoes of your developer
and operator team even if it's
days or months afterwards.
So we've seen that
there is an issue there,
but we know that the alert
happened on the cartservice.
So let's go back to
the cartservice again.
Let's see if we can
get more information
about the cartservice.
So as we are
exploring this, we're
noticing that the
cartservice itself
has an alert around that time.
So when you click on it,
we have the capability
to get some minimum
information about it,
and we can also have
this link that says
Go to the Service Dashboard.
So let's explore
where that takes us.
So what we built-- as long as
you're using the service mesh,
every single service
that you've deployed
will have an automatically
generated out
of the box dashboard for you.
Everything that you see right
here requires zero setup.
The only single thing
that you will have to do--
and that is your choice--
is to set up on SLO for it.
So let's look at the top.
We have an event timeline.
This is scoped to one day.
In red we actually see
every single incident
if it was caused by
an SLO-based alert.
When you hover over
it, you get information
around the alert status, the
time this alert was created,
and the duration.
We have a deep integration
with IRM, the incident response
management tool, that
will link you directly
to that alert for you to be
able to do further understanding
of what happened there.
You can go to your alert
policy as well in order
to make changes to that alert.
As we're looking to
the tab underneath,
you see that we are
on Overview tab.
These are the two key
things that we prioritized
when he showed this.
We really cared about
putting SLO health
as the number-one priority
for you to monitor.
And then you also have
at-a-glance metrics
and you have details
around your space.
Let's go next to the Health tab.
This is where you're
actually going
to spend a lot of
your time thinking
about your SLO management.
So we've created here three
SLOs, unavailability, latency,
and a second latency one.
You can see that you get
at-a-glance overview of which
ones are healthy, which
ones have an alert firing,
and which are out
of the SLO budget.
So let's open one of them.
As an SLO gets
created, you get an out
of the box mini
dashboard for that SLO
that gets generated for you.
You get a service-level
indicator, an error budget
remaining, and compliance.
You get your alert
attached to it
that you can create based
on every single SLO.
So if you can collapse this for
a second, what we can actually
see is that our
first SLO doesn't
have policies attached to it.
You can create SLOs
that you monitor,
and you create SLOs
that you alert on.
The entire creation, editing,
and deleting of an SLO,
our target is that you
need to accomplish that
under 30 seconds.
So let's try to create
an SLO right now.
There are three main features
that you need to add.
You decide your SLO type
and the threshold for it.
You decide on your SLO goal and
then on the compliance period.
As soon as you finish
this, you can click Submit,
and you can name it.
You get to the full name, but
you can make this personal
and name them yourself.
Once this gets created,
what you can see
is that SLO has been
generated immediately.
But more importantly, that
SLO has been evaluated.
Because we are able to get
this information directly
from Istio, we can go and look
back and pull this information
in and do a historical
evaluation of your SLO
and give you a status
within a couple of seconds
after the SLO has been created.
And we can delete
it just as fast.
Let's look at the
Metrics tab next.
When we think about metrics,
when we think about monitoring,
there is a lot of
engine deployment
and there's a lot
of back-end work.
Everything that you
see under this tab,
as long as you're
using the service mesh,
all of these metrics
are generated here.
All of the charts
Every time you end up
scoping on the event timeline
at the top, the time frame,
your charts get updated as well.
If you want to know something
around your metrics,
around an alert, and around
something you care about,
you get all of your
metrics right here.
These are the golden signals
that Dan talked about.
We have request counts, error
rate, latency, request size.
All of this information
comes out of the box.
Let's look at diagnostics next.
This is where we have an
integration with logging.
At the top of the
widget here you
are actually being able to see
a histogram of all of your logs,
and underneath we displayed
a select number of logs that
have been filtered by severity.
Again, if you're playing and
changing any of the event times
at the top, you're getting
an updated, refreshed view
instantaneously of your logs.
But we know this is not enough.
This is not enough information.
It gives you enough
information to know
if you want to decide to look
at the full logging experience.
So let's say we are
intrigued and we
want to look at the
full logging experience.
This has been generated
immediately for us,
and we have maintained context.
We are looking at the
exact same service
as we were looking in
the service dashboard,
and we are using the exact same
time spans from over there.
So we can do advanced
filtering here
without changing
the context at all.
Let's say we spent
some time in logs.
We found something
interesting, but we
want to go back to the
dashboard and investigate more.
The next thing we're
going to look about
is the infrastructure.
And this is where we have a very
strong integration with the GKE
team where we are
actually showing
all of the information around
the requests per second.
And also you have access
to be able to directly link
to the GKE pod's details
or to the GKE cluster
as well for more details.
So you don't have to change.
We are going to keep
the context for you.
So as you're doing all
of your investigation,
you are always
constantly looking
at the things you care about.
There is no filtering required.
And lastly, we're going to
look at connect services.
When we talk about root-cause
analysis, one of the key things
that we always ask
is is it my problem
or am I down the
funnel from something
bigger that I need
to pay attention to?
And we are able to show you only
the services that are inbound
and the services
that are outbound
to the particular
service you care about.
And let's say that it's one
service that you care about,
so maybe the front-end
service we want to explore.
You can actually go from
here and start this process
all over again.
So now we open the
service dashboard
for the front-end
service, and it gives you
the same visibility
and information
as we had before for
checkout service.
So hopefully this is not going
to be a rabbit hole of looking
at every single
service, but it's really
going to help you narrow down
the things you care about.
So thank you so much,
Patrick, for giving the demo,
and thank you so
much for your team
that ended up building
all of this amazing work.
So I want to welcome next Pod.
Can you give us
access to the slides?
OK, perfect.
So Pod is a
service-reliability engineer
working at Schlumberger, and
we are in a privileged position
to have been working
very closely with Pod
for a couple of quarters now.
And Pod has had early
access to our alpha program.
And we want to talk
to you a little bit.
We want to do this a
little bit more informal,
and we want to learn a little
bit about how Schlumberger's
architecture looks like.
PARDEEP SANDHU:
Thank you, Ruxanda.
Well, in Schlumberger
we used to have
a custom solution that allowed
us to both deploy and monitor.
However, this was very
difficult in the lift and shift
to the cloud.
We initially focused on
infrastructure monitoring
with Stackdriver.
However, this proved very
difficult for our teams.
We have both dev and
ops working together.
Our main goal at Schlumberger
is to bring the communities
together and create
an environment where
both our dev and
operations teams
can collaborate and
work closely together.
RUXANDA DANETIU: So
what's the direction
where Schlumberger's next?
PARDEEP SANDHU: We
wanted to target
a platform for modern-day
development that was flexible
and can empower us for the
hybrid cloud environment.
So we turned to Google
to take advantage
of the service-management
capabilities built
into the platform rather
than build those ourselves.
RUXANDA DANETIU: And
so I want to understand
what was the main reason why
you decided to use service mesh?
PARDEEP SANDHU: Well, there were
three main reasons we wanted.
One was to have a
Google-native managed solution.
The other was telemetry, and the
other was new-features rollout.
On the SRE team at
Schlumberger, we
care deeply to smartly
invest our time
and do effective work
for the organization.
As a result, we did not
want to focus our efforts
on managing our own Prometheus,
Grafana, or Istio stacks.
We needed to have a managed
solution because this
will empower us to focus
on what's important
and is a differentiator
across our team.
Secondly, we wanted
a solution that
offered powerful telemetry.
We wanted monitoring
capabilities
that could help us reduce the
workload for our developers
because the telemetry from Istio
goes straight to Stackdriver
out of the box, so
our developers don't
need to write that much code.
For us, what was
really important was
to have the golden
signals work just
like that without any
extra developer resources
and be able to create SLOs
without any homebrew solutions.
It just works.
Without any
configuration or setup,
we have charts, logs, and
SLOs all in one dashboard.
We have a single
pane of glass that
can help us monitor and
diagnose problems further.
Thirdly, it's great
when multiple teams
can work on the same
platform, especially when they
come from different angles.
For example, our architects
and product owners
were looking into
how to roll out
new features for a
subset of customers.
Istio has traffic management
so we can canary new features.
These capabilities were
key in our decision
to adopt Istio and GKE.
In the end, there's no
perfect solution out there.
However, the combination
of Istio and the alpha
dashboards, we ended up with
about 80% of what we wanted,
and we thought that was
pretty good if not great.
RUXANDA DANETIU: And so Pod,
you mentioned that SLOs ended up
becoming kind of a
key differentiator
for you making the decision
to adopt the service mesh.
So I wanted to know,
how do you decide?
What is the magic
number of SLOs?
How many SLOs do you build
for your organization?
PARDEEP SANDHU: Well, that's
a really hard question
to answer because we do not
come up with a target in mind.
It's not like we say we want
10 SLOs and everything should
fit into that number.
We actually spend a lot of time
across our functional teams
and try to organically come
up with a number that can help
our teams do their best work.
For example, we bucket
services together
so we can focus on a
small number of services.
We do not create SLOs for
each and every microservice.
However, we do take
an holistic approach
to the practice of SLO creation.
RUXANDA DANETIU: So tell us
more a little bit about that.
How do you decide if
a particular service
is worthy of having an SLO?
PARDEEP SANDHU: I
don't think it's
about a service being
worthy or not having an SLO.
We care about all our services.
However, we make decisions
based on our customers needs.
We have a user-journey
approach to SLOs.
For example, one
of our key actions
is for the user to be able
to log in and use our app,
so the availability of
our front-end service
is absolutely essential here.
However, the front-end
service talks to a number
of back-end services.
So here we create an
SLO for the availability
of the front end and the SLOs
for the back end it depends on.
So we can easily troubleshoot
in case of an incident.
Before we used to
create probes to see
if our back-end service was
down via alert notifications.
Now we can just create SLOs
for those back-end services.
RUXANDA DANETIU: So you
just mentioned user journeys
and being able to go into
your app and see the data.
So how do you decide on a
relevance of a user journey?
How do you prioritize
which user journeys
are going to have SLOs?
PARDEEP SANDHU:
Traditionally we used
to look at logs to determine
how the users were interacting
with our systems and any
problems that they were having.
However, we have now adopted a
much more comprehensive effort
around user journeys and
focusing on the customer.
This is a team
effort first of all.
Today we meet with our product
owners and subject-matter
experts, and in all
these conversations
we discuss what's critical
from a user's point of view.
The whole process is
extremely thoughtful
because this is the
foundation of everything
we will build afterwards in
terms of monitoring and SLOs.
Based on all this
information we collect from
our cross-functional teams, we
can prioritize the things we
should focus on--
for example, when should I wake
up in the middle of the night?
So in any service we
can degrade many things.
However, there are some things
that cannot and should not be
degraded because the entire user
experience is reliant on them.
So we always ask
ourselves, what is
fundamental part of the system?
What is crucial?
What is absolutely necessary?
So for each user journey, we
create several SLIs and SLOs
and monitor all
those SLOs together
so we can see the entire
user journey in one place.
RUXANDA DANETIU:
So you mentioned
you use a journey approach.
Do you create any
other types of SLOs
that are not customer
facing, for example?
PARDEEP SANDHU: Yes.
We have a two-prong
approach to SLOs.
First and foremost are
the customer user journey
driven SLOs because
we should know
before the customer does
if we have a problem
and we should fix it.
Secondly are the back-end SLOs
or the system-journey SLOs
because we need better
contracts between our teams.
At Schlumberger, we care about
external customers as much
as our internal customers.
So we have contracts
between the organizations,
and we apply the same level of
care to our internal contracts
as we do to our external users.
We call this the
friends-and-family contract
because if you
break your contract,
you're going to hear about
it again, again, and again.
So if a back-end service
has a clear dependency
for an internal
or external user,
this is something we
care deeply about.
It has to be up and running.
Our culture at
Schlumberger is to empower
many of the dev teams to be
as autonomous as possible.
And if a team wants autonomy
in our organization,
then that team needs to
maintain the contract
with the rest of the
teams and keep their SLOs
as part of that deal.
RUXANDA DANETIU: So you
mentioned the introduction
of internal contracts and
having SLOs based on them.
How has that changed the
culture at Schlumberger?
PARDEEP SANDHU: We
definitely think
it has changed for the better.
For example, in the
past we would have--
how shall I describe--
emotional discussions
when things go wrong,
and most of these conversations
would happen too late.
So now the main
difference is that we
can talk across teams
with actual data
to back those conversations.
This way we are now working
as a data-driven team,
and things are a lot more
clear and a lot less personal.
Having access to good data can
help us make better decisions,
communicate our intentions
and needs better as well.
RUXANDA DANETIU: So
I wanted to know--
Dan talked a lot
about error budgets,
and is that something
that Schlumberger uses?
PARDEEP SANDHU: Yes we do.
They don't look great right
now in our dev environments,
but we don't expect them to.
But what's important
is that now we
have the capabilities to see
them and reason about them.
Before, the idea of
SLO or error budgets
were just theory that we
read in many different books,
but we had no good
way of showing those.
Now everyone can see them.
If an internal or an external
dependency we depend on
goes down and a feature
in our app starts failing,
you can visually see how you're
blowing through your budget.
With these insights, we can
talk to the product owners
and agree upon a deal
when engineering should
focus on reliability tasks.
RUXANDA DANETIU: So
I wanted to know,
you've been using the
alpha for quite a bit now,
and we wanted to know what
is the next features that you
would need to be
build in the platform?
PARDEEP SANDHU: We're
looking forward to the day
when there's no manual setup
in any of the SLOs or error
budget.
I would love to see this
all automated in a way
to create them.
We want all this
as config as code,
even the configuration of the
creation of things like this.
So dashboards, SLO
setup, everything
should be something we
can generate automatically
and check into code.
RUXANDA DANETIU: So what are
the next steps for Schlumberger?
You've been using this alpha.
You've been testing it.
What do you intend to do next?
PARDEEP SANDHU: Well, I
work on a team Schlumberger
where we use Transformer names
for our software projects.
I'm lucky enough to work on
the Bumblebee project, the most
loved transformer, but
I get the opportunity
to work on many new
technologies and try
to work out how these will
best benefit our organization.
We call ourselves the cool kids
of Schlumberger due to the fact
that we get to play with the
new technologies out there,
but we've reached a
point with our engagement
with Istio where I need to
show to many other teams
and evangelize this
across Schlumberger a lot
more broadly.
We need to make an internal
culture shift in order
for us to adopt the SLO
framework wholeheartedly
and broadly at Schlumberger.
Our main barrier right
now is that this is alpha,
and we want to adapt this into
production as soon as possible.
RUXANDA DANETIU:
Thank you so much.
So Dan and I have
some work to do.
I really appreciate
your time, and I really
appreciate
Schlumberger committing
of using this as an
early alpha tester.
So thank you so
much for your time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]